morgen ist ein ganz ganz spannender tag
herr mohring es geht darum den fahrplan
vorzustellen wie geht's weiter in der
cdu wird neuer chef gewählt ihre these
vor
500 vier jahren hat martin luther in
wittenberg seine 95 thesen an die wand
geschlagen wenn ich glaube das thema
reformation und cdu das passt jetzt so
richtig gut zusammen am wochenende gab
sie preis zu den konferenzen erstmals
hat diese runde entschieden dass die
ganzen mitglieder befragt werden sollen
in der cdu wenn es darum geht wer wird
neuer parteivorsitzender entscheidend
hörster parteitag aber dass alle 400.000
cdu mitglieder gefragt werden das ist
wichtig und wenn wir jetzt reformation
machen wollen dann brauchen wir quasi
ein martin luther für die cdu der mit
seinen thesen für die erneuerung für die
umgestaltung der christlich
demokratischen union sein wort nacht
unter hin an dem sich alle versammeln
können ich habe mir zehn thesen
ausgedacht wird die kann man das
sprechen und es lohnt sich auf jeden
fall diesen prozess anzugehen diese
volkspartei wird gebraucht in der
demokratie in deutschland was sie muss
sich selbst erneuern muss die kraft
haben nach vorn zu schauen das
unterschreibe ich sofort was sie sagen
wenn sie aber jetzt mal hinschauen was
gerade heute wieder passiert es gibt
lauter kandidaten aus
nordrhein-westfalen wenn ich das richtig
sehe ist keiner aus einem anderen
bundesland dabei der gerne auch
vorsitzender werden möchte die sitzen
zusammen und versuchen aus zu kungeln
wer vorsitzender wird und wer ansonsten
in der erweiterten parteiführung
irgendwo funktion übernimmt oder
vielleicht sogar fraktionschef neben dem
parteichef wie auch immer das ist doch
das ganz die ganz alte cdu dies ja noch
älter als die vorangegangene also wir
haben ja zuletzt
entscheidungen auf parteitagen erlebt wo
mindestens zwischen zwei wenn nicht
sogar drei kandidaten gewählt werden
konnte jetzt versuchen die also
herzustellen ein zustand wo einer
ausgeguckt wird und die anderen alle
dazu nicken das ist doch nicht die neue
cdu oder der neue cdu soll daraus
bestehen dass nicht ein mann eine frau
von wegläuft sondern dass eine
mannschaft sich zusammenfindet und sagt
wir haben jetzt eine idee wie wir
gemeinsam erstes die breite der
volkspartei verkörpern könnte aber
gleichzeitig idee haben davon zu schauen
diese alten kämpfe die belastung der
personaldebatten der letzten zwei jahre
hat ja die cdu als zu weit in den keller
getrieben und die erfahrungen daraus ist
man muss die mitglieder beteiligen
sollte man auf jeden fall tun muß der
bundesvorstand morgen beschließen aber
dann ist es auch gut wenn es eine
teamlösung gebe große mannschaft eben
nicht nur einer nicht nur männer aus
nordrhein westfalen sondern aus der
breite der partei von den strömungen der
christlich liberalen der konservativen
der soziale der christsozialen eine
bereit unter konservativen dabei sind
ost und west berücksicht sinn genau wie
nord und süd wenn das gelingt dann ist
das eine mannschaft die funktionieren
kann und dann wenn sie nicht nur über
personal reden sondern endlich um
inhalte kümmern klar macht die
mitglieder werden auf dauer beteiligt
nicht nur jetzt einmal wenn es mir im
vorsitz geht sie können was ich meine
probleme der leute sie reden die klare
sprache sie finden bundeskonvent wo man
den kanzlerkandidaten gemeinsam
beteiligen kann und sie schauen darauf
dass sich als schwesterpartei nicht mehr
streiten sondern die fenster zumachen
und dann klären nach draußen geht wenn
man das alles tut dann hat die union
eine gute chance für die zukunft den
martin luther den sie gerne sehen wollen
den gibt es in der cdu dazu wird aber
vielleicht da dürfen zugleich lebt sie
ihn ja doch vielleicht gibt es in dem
lokal wird ihn nur gern wissen welchen
martin luther sehen sie dann sehr mir
davon klarer sprache es gibt nur
männchen in der cdu das ist das problem
aber wenn ich das sind aus dem menschen
sehen sie denn dann gibt es auch noch
einwandern wenn man das schon jetzt
wöchentlich machen will habe ich mir
also er wäre was essen wir wollen eine
klare sprache also sprechen sie wird
klartext ich glaube sie frau ich glaube
schon ich bin ein freund von dieser
teamlösung da müssen sich die leute um
carsten lindemann friedrich merz und
jens spahn auch zusammenfinden und
müssen eine lösung anbieten ich glaube
dann kann das funktionieren
und da muss man die breite der partei
gehen es gibt eine große sehnsucht dass
die mitglieder mitreden wollen aber dass
ihr wochen idee gibt wie diese männer
sich jetzt vorstellen können wie die
zukunft dieser union aussehen kann dann
muss schluss sein mit den debatten die
haben
gesagt doch nicht ewig drin wie beim
personal einmal ganz klar weil es immer
um die teamlösung geht das haben sie
jetzt gesagt wenn wir die namen uns
anschauen frau königs stelle fest gar
keine frau dabei ist das ein problem ist
die cdu für sie eine attraktive partie
eigentlich ohne eine frau im
spitzengremium also wo mich persönlich
geht es da kann ich glaube in dieser
ganzen personaldebatte legen wir viel zu
viel fokus auf die einzelnen video und
gar nicht auf dass ob das programm was
sie dann fortführen wollen und dass das
sehe ich auch jetzt in den letzten zwei
drei wochen wieder es geht wiederum nur
wer die meisten fürsprecher für sich
gewinnen kann wer weder eine partei
braucht natürlich gerade wenn sie in der
opposition ist braucht sie natürlich
eine galionsfigur 1 martin luther wie
mike mohring das gesagt
noch mal die frage herr mohring also wen
möchten sie als parteichef haben dazu
müssen sie drei mit sich ausmachen aber
ganz oben haben sie aber ganz
entscheidend ist weil es reicht weiß
porträts recht gefragt hatten die
mannschaft besteht nur dann wenn sie
eben auch in dieser breite frauen mit
abbildet wenn sie junge leute ab bildet
in die zukunft schaut wenn sie die
erfahrenen mitnimmt ost an west nord und
süd genauso berücksichtigt müssen die
drei auf ihren schultern leisten das ist
die mannschaft nicht nur aus diesen drei
leuten bestehen sondern sie müssen die
komplette führungsteam anbieten was ich
der partei vorstellen wollen wohin
geht's lang auf einem parteitag der
hoffentlich noch in diesem jahr
stattfindet ich finde und das müssen die
miteinander ringen ich und das ist ein
prozess der willicher bei ihnen das darf
nicht das hinterzimmer sein dass das
nicht nur eindrücke denken die alte cdu
macht schon wieder weiter sondern sie
muss die möglichkeit geben dass darüber
auch die partei abstimmt in ihrer
gesamten finde sie und ihre
parteifreunde im osten müssen sehr viel
klarer und lauter sagen dass da auch der
osten berücksichtigung aller umstände
ganze wahlkampf hat sich völlig im osten
vorbei entwickelt das programm geht
vorbei es wird über die frage von
wohnungsnot im westen geredet die gibt
es im osten gar nicht da sind da stehen
häuser leer da müssen häuser abgerissen
werden weil es eine landflucht gibt und
in die städte hinein oder sogar ein
investment die problemlage ist völlig
unterschiedlich und der osten spielt in
der wahrnehmung des westens in der cdu
aber auch darüber hinaus überhaupt keine
rolle mehr er hat also ein fahrer
gekommen wo ihr mal sagt ohne uns geht
jetzt hier nichts mehr promis hat gesagt
sie brauchen ich bin ganz neu auch in
ein programm sie haben wollen wäre mehr
das programm als die figuren korrekt
korrekt also ich sehe es einfach gerade
nicht wie wir da eine starke durchsetzen
ich kann mich auch nicht wie sich da ein
starkes team herauskristallisiert hat
den letzen zwei wochen somit würde es
wirklich darum gehen welches team hat
die offenheit und wiederum ein
parteiprogramm anzuführen das dann
wiederum integrierend wirkt dass die
offenen meinungen zwischen ost und west
mit aufnimmt aber dann noch mal konkret
was sag ich mal als
jungwähler die ich ja immer noch bin an
sie wofür werden sie denn dann will
darin ja selbstständig
also ist ganz klar wir müssen endlich
auch ein bisschen personaldebatten diese
zwei jahre haben die partei gelähmt sich
diskutiert nicht mehr über inhalte weil
ich mache jetzt schluss der debatte und
sage und ja sie können aber wir sagen
ich muss mal 40 mal entschieden da muss
man sagen das ist eine frage beim
parteitag entscheidet entscheider das
problem ist er nicht die falsche
entscheidung sondern die entscheidung
dass man nicht vertraut hat und hinter
jemandem gestanden ist jemand gewählt
hat sondern kaum nach der wahl schon
wieder infrage gestellt hat parteien
leiden darunter bands ihre eigene
führungspersonal nicht vertrauen wenn
sie den nicht zutrauen wenn sie sich
streiten dann wenden sich die leute ab
unionswähler renten sich das recht ab
und wenn wir inhalte brauchen wir nach
vorne schauen wollen wenn es darum geht
wie kann dieses land voran gehen dann
muss die cdu eine alternative bieten zu
dem was die ampel sich derzeit anbietet
mit der falscher finanzminister
drankommt geht es um die schulden union
in europa wenn die grünen sich
durchsetzen bei den ampelphasen da geht
es um eine neue flüchtlingspolitik der
geest wenn ein neuer asylpolitik wenn
die sich durchsetzen sowie jahren
verhandeln später osten keine rolle bin
ich ganz bayern jägers dann findet noch
weniger oststadt als vorher osten statt
gefasst werden sich einfach zu an die
ampel partei nein gesagt nicht mit
nüssen zu alternative zu werden wir
müssen die bessere regierung seien auch
in der opposition das ist die
verantwortung die die union hat die
union hat immer das
verantwortungsprinzip
braucht eigentlich immer sozusagen die
mit gestaltungsoptionen hinter der osten
in der cdu muss ich ein stück weit
selbständig machen das ständige
positionen formulieren eine
eigenständige politik in den ländern
betreiben sowie das andere ja auch schon
tun in den in den westlichen ländern in
na ja bis jetzt nicht mehr umreißen
bayern ist schon immer so gewesen es
muss einfach jetzt ein eine eine
information an erwachsenwerden der
ostdeutschen landesverbände geben am
ende muss man doch sagen ist das ein
scherbenhaufen den angela merkel
hinterlässt also sie hinterlässt eine
partei sie tritt ab hinterlässt eine
partei in trümmern und sie ist eine
ostdeutsche aber sie hat es nicht
geschafft offenbar diesen punkt zu
machen zu sagen ich gebe auch den
ostdeutschen verbänden eine eigene
identität überhaupt der partei ein
sprungbrett sich auch zu selbst zu
modernisieren und dann in eine neue zeit
zu gehen das hat sie sträflich etwa drei
monaten zu diskutieren sie hat ihr
diesen regierungsjahren diesen art
halbjahr 10 vergessen zu diskutieren das
haben sie ja gut angesprochen ist genau
der punkt eine partei lebt davon dass
sie das kurs führt das führen wieder
miteinander bespricht das ist nicht
streit sondern das ist die debatte um
die beste lösung und das hat die cdu
verlernt und das muss dann hat sie auch
eine chance wieder dass die inhalte
wahrgenommen werden aber wäre nicht über
inhalte diskutiert dass die inhalte
werden auch nicht wahrgenommen und wir
wissen auch sie mit der ampel aber mit
uns selbst auch ring was ist die beste
lösung und ich bin bei ihnen der osten
muss nicht deutlichere klare sprache
finden er muss klartext formulieren und
er muss wenn eine chance haben will sich
auch stärker vernetzen wir sind auch so
ein bundesparteitag ungefähr zehn
prozent der delegierten von dem
rennsteig bis zur ostsee da finden wir
nicht statt wenn wir nicht die
unterstützung aus west verwenden
bekommen ich bin der bundesvorstand war
bundespräsidium der partei das ist nur
gelungen bei mir die freunde aus den
anderen verbänden ihrem
einsatz zu angela merkel treffen sie und
die frau ist 200 2018 aus dem
cdu-vorsitz ausgeschieden und in diesem
moment hat sie die cdu aufgegeben sie
hat sich für die nicht mehr interessiert
und es ist geradezu zynisch wenn sie
heute sagt sie die parteivorsitz und
kanzleramt gehören in einer hand dann
hätte es ihnen halbes jahr später auch
als kanzlerin gehen müssen wäre
vielleicht nicht schlecht gewählt wird
aus ihrer sicht wer macht das rennen
jetzt
ist vollkommen offen nein wir ferner
chef
ich wünsche nicht dass das diese anlagen
wird das ist nicht friedrich merz wird
wenn ich kann keinen ausdruck und
ehrlich gesagt ich würde mir unter den
gegebenen schlechten lösungen dann noch
die lösung sparen wünschen der
skizzierung philipp petrow der cdu-chef
es läuft alles auf friedrich merz hinaus
ja leider turniers
ich schließe mich dem an aber ich glaube
auch dass wir das da auch wir als sage
ich mal oder die medien auch eine ganz
andere aufgabe haben die person nicht so
bezeichnen sondern wirklich mal wieder
die inhalte glänzt zu lassen und das
finde ich ein großes problem friedrich
merz und sie sagen hat einer von den
dreien wird werten und musste vier
anderen beziehen lassen sich einsatz
noch sagen zu angela merkel die hat am
wochenende ein spannendes interview
gegeben weil sie noch mal zu ihrer rede
von dritten oktober was gesagt hat und
sie hat anerkannt dass sie zu wenig die
ostdeutsche war als kanzlerin für
gesamtdeutschland und tatsächlich das
kann man eigentlich finanzieren wenn sie
das stärker herausgestellt hätte mit
dieser biografie die sie hatte und diese
auszeichnet
hätten sich mehr leute auch über die
jahre hinweg ihr verbunden gefahr aber
nicht angela merkel immer wieder leute
heißt
ich muss da mal zwischen aber jetzt ist
ja dass so was sagte politikchef von
bild wer wird friedrich merz aber ich
mag auch mal falsch